so at the very least of Silence so that
we don't disturb the flow of the meeting
you'll know the meeting is a meeting in
public not a public meeting so only the
people that are registered to speak will
be permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I will call you forward to one of
the many speakers in in microphone sorry
in front of you we do have new AV kit um
it's fairly straightforward to use so
when you are sat the button on the right
hand side of the of the speaker will go
if you press that it will go red and
you'll be able to speak you will be live
um obviously when you're done if you
could press it to turn it off and that
will direct the camera away from you so
uh so you're no longer on screen
um
we are not expecting any fire alarms so
if one does go off please follow us uh
in an orderly fashion across the car
park next to the windmill Pub
um we will need to check all your names
off our register to make sure everyone's
got out the building safely so please
make sure you're there and once you've
been checked off we can send you on your
Merry Little way
um some introductions uh now if I may so
to my far right we have Howard Allison
who is our Community Services
representative to my immediate writer
Sue Mullins who is our solicitor and our
plan is no particular order ah Charlotte
Dix Alison Withers and Victoria Kempton
and to my immediate left is our planning
manager Alice Cosner Alice I think
you've got a statement to make I do
thank you chairman my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
fabulous thank you very much indeed
right let's get into the meeting itself
so first of all do we have any apologies
for absence please
yes chair we have apologies from
counselor Curtis for whom we have
councilor together substituting
councilor Foreman for whom councilor
Cargill is substituting councilor Rock
for whom councilor Ralph is substituting
councilor Mills and councilor Crump
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any disclosures of Interest please
Council Dixon first
thank you chairman uh in respect of item
seven it's application
22-02099 f u l
I am the chairman of the trust which is
the applicant in that case I will leave
the committee and speak on behalf of the
applicant thank you marvelous thank you
very much just on that same item um it
is for a cricket Wicket I believe and uh
I should disclose that I am a cricketer
uh albeit an ex cricketer I'm a little
too old to play anymore I haven't played
at tanworth um uh and I'm here with an
open mind so I will remain on the
committee for that decision Council
Cargill next please
thank you chair yes item two which is 22
01958 full I am the ward member for that
um application uh although I believe
that there has been uh movement on that
particular point
thank you very much Council Rolf
button on the right I've done it
thank you uh I need to declare an
interest on the first item on the agenda
York house uh
2201533 as I am the county councilor
for that Ward
you'll be remaining on the committee
though you're here with open mind is
that right
yes I will be marvelous thank you very
much anyone else
um so I've got one more to uh disclosure
to make I think we've all received late
on this evening
um a message from the uh War member for
the piloton uh item which is application
it's number six on our agenda
application twenty two zero zero zero
three zero ful
um unfortunately uh there has been
um a a medical emergency is probably the
wrong thing to say probably over does it
but there is uh there is something that
happened at home that has caused the the
war member to not be able to be here
tonight um she has provided to all of us
a copy of her uh representation I have a
copy in front of me and I'll be reading
that out at the appropriate time just so
that everyone is aware of that so unless
there are any other declarations to make
uh we will move to the minutes is
everyone happy with the minutes as
presented in the agenda pack and we're
quick I can see lots of nodding heads
yeah okay I will sign those after the
meeting uh has finished
um okay so let's move into our
applications themselves now as you've
heard from uh Council Cargill there has
been some movement on application
2201958 ful Rosie's Orchard in bidfood
upon Avon um the committee trigger which
is uh the ward member and the parish
council
um uh objections they have been removed
so we will be delegating that decision
to the officers so that item will no
longer be heard tonight
um right let's move into our first full
application which is application
reference
2201533 ful and
2201534 LBC uh that's York house and
Rother Street our presenting officer is
Charlotte Dix Charlotte over to you
thank you chairman
the site is indicated on the map by the
black circle the application site is
within the town center and built at area
boundary of Stratford
this slide shows the application site
edged in Black the site fronts onto
Rother Street to the East and is fairly
a linear in shape projecting up to
Greenhill street car park on the western
side
there's a pedestrian access from
Greenhill Street to the north as well as
from Rother street car park to the South
the red building shown on the plan are
all listed buildings with York house
itself being grade 2 listed
the site is within the conservation area
and there's a mix of town center and
residential uses nearby
this is a full planning application
unlisted building consent for the
demolition of the site
much of the existing extensions to the
rear of the building would would be
demolished with the commercial elements
being redeveloped
in addition nine new townhouses would be
built to the rear of the site
the site plan at the top of this slide
shows the existing site layout where the
proposed site plan shown below
the York house Frontage and as seen on
the right hand side of the screen would
be retained in commercial use with
townhouses one to seven to the rear of
this
separated from this part of the scheme
would be townhouses eight and nine which
would abut the existing residential uses
nearby
there's no vehicular access to the site
for parking
so this slide shows the existing
elevations at the top of the screen with
the proposed elevations shown below
these elevations are as viewed from the
rear of the properties on Green Hill
Street
you can see the proposed first for bow
windows and roof Gardens and some of the
design features mentioned within the
report
this slide shows the existing and
proposed elevations as viewed from the
playhouse and the Rother street car part
to the South I just want to draw your
attention to the proposed elevations
including the the flat roof design and
glazing element referred to in the
report
to provide an idea of the proposed floor
space and level of development I have
included the proposed first floor plan
on this slide this shows the proximity
to the surrounding built form
for example the two-story walls to the
North and South
of the development
the distance from the windows on the
Northern elevation would be
approximately three meters from the flat
element of the wall to the the boundary
wall here minimize well that'll be
minimized to about two meters for some
of the townhouse bow windows
so this slide shows the proposed second
floor plan
so this is showing the living space at
second floor level as well as the roof
Gardens which are proposed for all of
the townhouses
this photo is taken from Rother street
so showing the French elevation of York
house you'll note there predominantly
two-story modest development on the
corner of Brother house and Green Hill
streets with only the Civic Playhouse
building being larger than this
this photo is taken from Green Hill
Street showing the existing pedestrian
access into the site you can see the
proximity of two of the nearby hot food
takeaways on the road Frontage as well
as the rear elevation of the playhouse
as you look through the pedestrian
entrance to the rear of the photo
on the right hand side is number 34
Green Hill Street which is mentioned in
the report
so this photo is taken from within the
site showing the existing extensions and
printing works on the left hand side so
this is looking West as shown by the
arrow on the plan on the right hand side
you can see the wall and existing Green
Hill Street development on the right
hand side of the photo
so this photo shows the location of
townhouse 8 where the location townhouse
8 would be on the left hand side and
then the rear and side elevations of
number 34 Green Hill Street as shown by
the arrow here
this vote is taken from within the
existing building looking towards number
34 Greenhill Street the windows for the
kitchen referred to in the report are
shown centrally in the photo
you can also see the Grove house
development at the rear of the photo
so this photo is taken from Green Hill
Street Car Park as indicated on the map
so this is looking towards where
townhouses eight and nine would be
located again you can see number 34
Green Hill Street on the left hand side
now and Grave house on the right hand
side
so just to clarify there are a few
updates within the update sheet and
please also note that the amended plans
are referred to in the update she were
in fact received on the 17th of January
this year rather than 17th of February
so officer recommendation is to refuse
planning permission and list of building
consent applications for redevelopment
of the site to create nine new dwellings
in line with the reasons and notes on
pages 31 and 32 of the agenda
thank you chair
sure thank you very much indeed Ryan
let's call our first Speaker of the
evening who is councilor Ian fragley of
Stratford private Town Council
good evening councilor for Ashley
and we've seen you many times before so
I think you've got a good idea of how
things are going to go but you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up once
you're sat comfortable and ready to go
if you press the button on the right
your microphone will be activated and
the time is yours
foreign
the principal have new homes within the
Town Center boundary with the Proviso
have also maintaining the town Town's
green spaces is fully supported by
Stratford Town Council
as our client in Stratford's
neighborhood plan policy H1
and as a result there has already been a
number of housing applications over
shops in Bridge Street High Street and
Union Street and there are potentially
more in the pipeline such as the winds
Windsor Street Cinema site and a Bard's
walk rooftop as well as this particular
application
Stratford Town Council when welcomed
such developments in the Town Center
which it believes will add to the
vibrancy and economic success of the
town
and the so so the Town Council is in
support of this particular application
items that we as a Town Council did
request some clarification on came uh
via email from the case officer and the
town counts resulting in the Town
Council being pleased that this
development pays some attention to
climate change in the inclusion of air
source heat bumps and Heat exchangers
although I understand PVS will not be
included and given the town center
location and restrictions on access and
deliveries there is to be a construction
Environmental Management plan
and as an add-on the developers also
informed the Town Council that they will
provide appropriate bicycle parking and
this will include electric
sockets for charging electric bikes
thank you
thank you very much Council fragile if
you could turn your microphone off for
me for a moment please uh members do we
have any questions for our speaker
councilor Rolf please
um thank you councilor for actually
um
I am a member of the Town Council so
maybe I should declare an interest I
don't sit on planning but I would like
to ask you the following question are
you you haven't mentioned parking is it
something you have a problem with in
terms of parking in the center of town
I understand that parking is no longer a
a consideration for these these uh
expanding into the town within the town
boundary
so but is it a consideration for you as
a town councilor that that the uh nine
nine properties will produce nine
possibly 18 cars
parking in and around the town center
which is already congested is it
something you discussed at planning at
Town Council
uh we take it that we do not have to
worry about parking in in uh for people
living in the Town Center
and that's written down somewhere
Council Roth but I can't tell you where
and I think if you think that's a
problem wait till you get the
um the application from the uh Winter
Street
let's not talk about applications that
we're not here to listen to please
um okay councilor Dixon next please
thank you chairman councilor treasury um
the report before is uh has quite a
lengthy section on residential amenity
uh specifically the Privacy impacted by
or certainly as far as the plan is
concerned the Privacy impacted upon the
neighbors of this one should it go ahead
has the Town Council discussed uh their
comments at all in the light of the
comments from the planning officer
that was not under our consideration
councilor Parry please
good evening councilor fragile
um I would just be interested in your in
the council's views obviously York house
is grade two listed and in the officers
report
whilst the drawings show that there's a
large external chimney stack that being
retained there's also potentially part
of the 17th century fabric missing from
from the existing and proposed drawings
um I'm just interested to know what your
views are on this on on having such an a
significant part of this um the fabric
of the building not present and that has
been removed
am I on yes
um I'm here I'm not here representing
myself I'm here representing the Town
Council
um and we we have not actually you know
in-depth depths discuss that particular
item
okay Council cargo next please before
Council cargo speaks and you say If
people could move their microphones a
little bit closer to them I saw this
sort of height
um whilst they are picking you up it's
not necessarily being projected around
the room properly so just as a reminder
cancel Cargill please thank you
councilor Frankie just a comment please
on the uh the bin storage and access
because they say Obviously The Refuge
Vehicles can't get into the site there
so I'm presuming that now occasionally
we all have four bins to put out on one
day as it just happens uh what about the
access and and storage of those on the
pavement has that been considered
um may I recommend Council Cargill that
you you you might want to go to a site
visit
I have actually been to have a look a
couple of days ago and I can't see any
particular problem in moving the bins
okay councilor Harvey please
the report contains the following
sentence I do not consider there would
be any private amenity space provided
for any of the townhouses
I'm
does the Town Council have a view about
the provision of immunity space because
from the officer's statement that seems
to be a fairly absolute statement there
is none is the Town Council aware of any
amenity space available
no we are not aware of any amenity space
okay have we got any more questions for
our town councilor no in that case
cancel the fragile thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
okay and what councilor Frederick's
making his way back we'll call our next
speakers now we have a full Squad of
applicants and agents so first of all we
have Gail Collins uh we have Mel Kang we
have Phil Powell and we have Martin
Court are you all four coming up to the
table in front of us
if you're if you're here to answer
questions if you want to make your way
up you may be called upon you may not
but at least you're in the right place
that would be fantastic
so who do I have directly in front of me
who's going to be doing the main
speaking is that yourself sorry I don't
know who your name is yeah I'm Gail
Collins planning agent marvelous okay
Miss Collins then you will have three
minutes I will give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up uh
otherwise when you're set and ready the
floor is yours thank you um good evening
I'm pleased that the report recognizes
this Brownfield site is in the
district's most sustainable location for
housing and that the principal and scale
of development is acceptable we've been
down the pre-application route nearly
two years ago starting with a 16
dwelling scheme with an additional story
height the amended scheme has been
significantly reduced to a smaller and
lower nine unit development at the heart
of this proposal is the refurbishment of
the listed York house
this scheme proposes the opening up of
the site through the demolition of large
and sympathetic extensions it proposes a
row of energy efficient upside down town
houses on a smaller footprint with
private roof Terrace immunity space and
shared amenity space Landscaping tree
planting benches alongside the bike
store it's been mentioned the proposals
reflect the site's historic layout are
subservient in height to the listed
building and The Print Works there were
only two objections received to the
original larger scheme and the proposal
has satisfied your planning policy
highways drainage fire service and other
consulties therefore we're extremely
disappointed with the recommendation on
Heritage grounds there is a clearly a
misunderstanding about the works
proposed the listed building no works or
alterations are proposed the 17th
century building all chimneys are
staying your conservation officer
confirms she does not consider that
demonstrable harm is caused to the
character or setting of the listed
building in terms of the conservation
area the existing development is
unattractive and detracts from its
character and appearance policy does not
require proposals to copy historic
elements and in the report's conclusion
and planning balance the public benefits
are replacing an unrestricted General
industrial use are not referenced this
is a key test in the planning balance in
terms of noise a pragmatic approach to
address any noise concerns is needed to
bring this site forward for residential
use some of the commercial units on
Greenhill Street have restrictions on
noise and hours of operation which could
be enforced the applicant owns the Flats
next to the site adjacent to the dolphin
fish bar and has no record of complaints
and your development requirements SPD
says that non-opening windows are
acceptable in certain situations but the
report does not address why mechanical
or passive ventilation is unacceptable
here
in terms of immunity for future
residents your officers report on
daylight and sunlight is incorrect as
our submitted report confirms that
overall levels are acceptable and to
confirm the immediate flanking buildings
our single story they rise up to
two-story but they are single story
height 30 seconds in respect of a
private immunity space we've got the
roof Gardens and Terraces which again
are set out in your development
requirements and in terms of neighbors
to the site no objections have been
received from Grove house and the
building is already impacted upon by the
existing building and windows can be
altered if needed in 34 Greenhill Street
as this is the applicant's property in
summary the Heritage noise and amenity
issues can be overcome by amended plans
or planning conditions this is a site
where residential development is
supported by policy it brings a listed
building back into a viable use and will
contribute to the center's vitality and
viability there are significant public
benefits arising I'm afraid I'm going to
have to stop you there because okay I've
just gone over your time but thank you
very much
uh members do we have any questions for
any of the power that are in front of us
Council roll first please
good evening uh you mentioned
um that uh there are things that can be
overcome by a condition
um do you have any views on how you can
overcome
the noise issue being so close to the
playhouse when the playhouse is
performing and their back door is open
and people are outside do you have any
thoughts as to how you could overcome
this problem
um yes if I may
um I've we've got the noise consultant
here who actually looked specifically at
the noise from the playhouse and a
survey was done of the noise in the
worst case scenario and was found to be
acceptable and that has been accepted by
by your environmental health officer as
well
Okay so
I follow up vice versa
uh um you know if it's a sunny evening
and and people have their windows open
on the on the proposed development
the noise from there to the playhouse
um good evening
um yes we carried out a um a noise
survey to represent a worst case
scenario with a with a live jazz band
playing at the at the playhouse and
nothing was audible at the uh proposal
uh it it correspondedly makes sense that
should anybody be on there uh balcony
enjoying a evening in the summer or
whatever
um the the reciprocal will be the same
there shouldn't be any impact at the at
the playhouse given the structure of the
playhouse
okay Council Parry next please
thank you chair good evening
um I just wonder whether you can explain
um I mean it might might be an error but
um it was a similar question I posed to
councilor fragile as to why the
applicant has decided not to include
this external stack that is part of the
17th century fabric of the building in
your plans
um
I'd just like to know why it because
obviously it's a it's a key part being
in the conservation area and it would be
helpful to have a good understanding of
that thank you
but button on the right should do the
job if it doesn't there's a little card
in front of you if you swipe out on the
left side it should activate and then
you press the button on the on the right
we're on fabulous hi I'm the architect
for this game
sorry that we might have a glitch on it
I did say it before this is all a new AV
Equipment and that one suddenly has
decided to turn off so if you want to
use the the one to your left
fabulous sorry about that thank you can
you hear me now yeah
um I'm Phil Powell I'm the architect for
the scheme
um the chimney is actually retained and
I think what has happened is that the
survey drawings upon which the scheme
has been based don't actually show the
chimney poking through the the roof but
we we have confirmed on many occasions
now that there is no intention to take
that chimney out at all for it to be
removed from the the scheme and that
also includes his external stacking
sorry I mean and and it includes the
external stack now the drawings that
we've issued to Charlotte recently
actually show that that chimney is shown
on the roof plan now so it was it was
hands up it was an error on our part
that it wasn't we hadn't picked it up
but there is no intention to remove it
at all
thank you councilor Cargill please thank
you good evening
um can you describe to me please how
you're going to protect the immunity of
the the residents especially when you
were talking about the roof Gardens as
well because obviously you need to
protect that privacy and such like how
can you do that please
if in terms of protecting the amenity
from each other between the houses the
roof structure does actually extend down
and create a storage area for the for
the roof Terrace so there's somewhere
effort to put furniture and that sort of
thing within a covered area but that is
that that is a structure which creates a
privacy between each of the roof Gardens
chairman so are we talking about a what
a one meter two meter section between
the the um the actual it's roof height
so it it it I think it will be reducing
from Two and a Half meters down to one
and a half meters maybe but certainly
there's going to be no visual
um
uh impact between each of the uh the
roof Gardens you won't be able to see
one roof gone from the other
thank you
okay do we have any more questions for
our applicants agents and Architects
councilor Harvey please can I can I
repeat my question I posed to councilor
fredly
um the statement in the report that
gives me some concerns is I the officer
I do not consider there would be any
private immunity space provided for any
of the townhouses
could you respond to that
absolutely the whole concept is based
upon an upside down house so in other
words the amenity the private immunity
space is at roof level and each house
has its own roof Terrace independent of
all the other Terraces so it's not true
to say that it has no private immunity
space every house has private amenity
space of anywhere between
7 and 11 square meters they're different
because there are different types of of
houses but then there is on top of that
shared communal space as well at Grand
level which I think extends to well over
300 square meters of of space and we've
we have centered the development around
two Courtyard areas where there are
trees and benches and other features
green Walls we're introducing into the
scheme as well so there is a mixture of
shared Community shared amenity space
and very definitely private amenity
space for every for every dwelling
okay thank you very much cancer seraphim
please
hello there
um could you give me some idea of the
size of the study rooms
that's a good question
um off the top of my head I think it's
around about eight nine square meters
something like that
the study rooms appear in units
um six and seven
and I think Charlotte has picked up the
fact that they could be converted into
bedrooms so that those units could be
could be could become three bedroom
units but I would say and this was this
was a point that was made to the Town
Council we don't see these as family
homes we see these as probably
downsizers people wanting to move into
the into the town center but we don't we
don't think it's the sort of place where
families will want to bring children so
if somebody wanted to use that study as
a bedroom there'll be nothing to stop
them but we see it as a study we see it
more likely that even the two-bedroom
units are going to be used most of the
time as single bedroom units with two
people in them but they'll be able to
have guests and maybe use that other
second bedroom as a study
okay thank you very much councilor
together please
thank you
um so the Town Council
station mentioned the benefits of some
of the design features in relation to
tackling climate change so can you tell
us a little bit more about those and
also I think
um a bicycle storage with electric uh
charging for electric bicycle was
mentioned but I can't see that in the
report so is that going to be proposed
as well and why is it not in the report
thank you
I can't comment why it's not in the
report but it's certainly part of our
proposals that the it was something the
Town Council specifically asked for that
electric charging points would be
provided within the bicycle storage and
we'll we'll definitely be providing
those in terms of our approach to The
Climate emergency we follow what's
called a fabric first approach to
development I.E you increase and put as
much insulation into a into a building
as is possible and also to limit the
amount of air permeability of those
buildings now what that then in turn
relies upon is an mvhr system which is a
mechanical ventilation heat recovery
system
but also all of this is tied to using
air source heat pumps which I know is
something that's very sort of you know
part part of the the government strategy
encouraging people to use Airsoft seed
pumps each unit will have its own air
source heat pump which will be connected
to underfloor low temperature underfloor
heating systems
at councilor fragile mentioned that
there weren't actually any PVS we
haven't said that what we've said so
yeah we're straying a long way from the
question I think now which was mainly
focused around the bikes I I think it
was your overall strategy I think you
asked about was it our overall strategy
or have I strayed beyond your your
question well I would like to know if
you're going to provide PV
um you know renewable energy in this
case I'm sorry it is it is actually
indicated on the diagram that we
produced for as part of our
sustainability strategy that there was
potential to put PVS in and without
wanting to put words in my client's
mouth who's here he's actually committed
to putting those in but it would be part
we we would see the whole m e the whole
mechanical electrical strategy has been
part of a condition for us to supply
that information but it could be
conditioned
sorry for interrupting you there cancer
Parry
thank you I'll come back again I know
you highlighted about the amended plans
of but now have this stack and I notice
in the update sheet
um obviously as as you had explained
that the officers hadn't time to
consider the amended plans are there any
other were there any other significant
changes in the amended plans that would
I'm just interested to know
um apart from any other Corrections that
we might not be aware of that were part
of the original plan that might have
been left off by by the drawings yes
um there are two modern partitions at
first floor level that we had indicated
in outline on our plan and in the
amended plans that we've submitted to
Charlotte we've shown those partitions
as retained
um that they're not part of the 17th
century building there's something that
was installed in the 1950s or 60s we
think as as part of the office refurb
that was was carried out
um but just for clarity we've made sure
that they're shown has been retained
whereas before we just shown them in
outline
I think that and I I I've explained to
Charlotte that I think that is probably
one of the reasons why there was so much
confusion as to what it was that we were
actually proposing to do to the 17th
century to the 17th 17th century part of
the the building just to reiterate there
are no Works proposed other than repairs
and restoration
cancer Dixon please
thank you chairman
um I'm coming and looking at the report
on page 23 the central paragraph there
is referring to the privacy of neighbors
um I remember that Gail in her comments
Etc commented that there hadn't been any
objections from nearby residents Etc
however that does not necessarily cover
the case as to whether or not their
privacy will be impacted by these
proposals would you like to talk to that
particular aspect please
yeah I think that this this comment
probably related more than anything else
to units eight and nine which uh replace
what is at the moment at all but single
story building and the concern that
Charlotte had was the the impact upon
the um the adjoining building which
actually belongs now to our to our
client
um
and perhaps this is something that needs
to be discussed but we we were content
that the way that we designed the
building wouldn't impact upon the
privacy of those those units because
those units have Windows facing in other
directions than the the two kitchen
windows which are the the the main point
of concern
if I'm a chairman I don't think it was a
matter of light it was a matter of
privacy
obviously if you've got the view into
it's irrespects irrelevant as to what
that window serves unless there is dual
light we we understand the we understand
the comments and and uh we we would take
that on board but we can we think that
there are options to address that
particular concern in detail one of
which is to make alterations to the
building at number 34 as well as maybe
making alterations to the scheme
proposals but we're open to discussion
on that
thank you
okay do we have any more questions for
our applicant agents and everyone else
no in that case to all of you thank you
very much for your time and contribution
this evening
okay we will move to our final speaker
on this item who is councilor Jenny
fragley our Ward member
councilor franchley you will have five
minutes I will give you a 30 second
morning before your time is up once
you're settled and comfortable button on
the right and the floor is yours
foreign
thank you very much
um
the application is for nine townhouses
and it's been reduced with 15 and the
refurbishment of a grade two listed
building
the interior listed building is in the
sorry State and needs sensitive
attention to create the commercial rooms
that will provide quality employment
opportunities in the center of the town
in the Conservation Area
seven townhouses will occupy the
footprint of the existing 20th century
paintworks 19th 20th century paintworks
while the remaining two will be in a
separate building at the end of the plot
close to townhouse
which will provide quality residences in
a sustainable site contributing to the
vibrancy and economic success of the
town this principle is agreed by SDC as
well as ystc
I agree this is a narrow plot of land
that this Innovative design has produced
in all nine spacious townhouses with
good immunity space I must emphasize
that each one of these properties has
space to walk out outside and sit and
enjoy the outside space
first floor it's a Saturn fall Garden
for each dwelling
more private space than many times
Center homes afford
they're also two further immunity spaces
one small space to the north with two
trees along the access
Corridor and one to the West providing a
large open space
between the seven town houses and the
townhouse eight nine there's two more
trees cycle storages we've heard
electric charging points spin stores
with easier and the binsos have easy
access to Greenhill Street you saw the
passageway in the in the photographs
provided
at the moment this area is a rubbish
dump with all kinds of litter
we've talked about the chimney stack I
don't think I need to say that anymore I
think we know about Jimmy stack
um comets are made about ground floor
Windows looking onto the brick wall
close to the Arts house
uh
there are however on the first floor
there is a light well which actually
allows light to flood into those
bedrooms from the first floor and
they're the Oriole windows on the other
side which provide views into the
passageway
that connects the front doors
um the exhaust systems on the dolphin
fish and chip shop have been highlighted
as a potential issue for noise and
smells we've heard about the mitigation
that takes place to to control that from
within the construction of these houses
however 34 Greenhill street is at a
similar distance from the fish bar
um
as we've gone through
um
there's some some comments have been
made about the Contemporary design being
uh at odds with the conservation area I
think we all agree that we actually live
in the 21st century and we should be
leaving a footprint of our own views and
attitudes towards um architecture and
living space and we've heard that this
is actually going to be well insulated
it's going to have solar gain it's going
to have
um
ground source
heat Source pumps so I think we're
covering and actually showing to the
Next Generation some generations to come
on this small site are really
fascinating Innovative uh development
that will actually provide
residences for downsizes which is
particularly important and also vibrancy
for the town
I'm aware that I've been listening there
have been a lot of confusions about what
is here what is there does this work no
amenity space when their patently is
if you are tall concerned about what
view you would give to this to refuse or
approve
especially if your mind is refuse before
you do that you should certainly make a
site visit
if you go to the site and see exactly
what is on offer there it clarifies the
the information you've been given in the
sheets a lot of which has been confused
and you've been questioning it so I as a
ward counselor
30 seconds really support this
development I think it adds to the town
center I'm looking forward to the
historic building being brought back
into commercial use and I support the
proposal
Council fragie thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our Ward member please Council Rolf
um thank you um
site visits
um I mean as you as you know and I've
had my hand
slapped on many occasions about not
asking for a site visit
um
I personally think
that a site visit would actually
you're moving towards debate at the
moment have you got a question for
councilor for actually please
uh
no I haven't
okay thank you um does anyone else have
a question for our world member no in
that case counter strategy thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
uh now members we will now move to
points of clarification to our officers
I'm going to kick us off because I must
admit I am frightfully confused now
um we've heard about amended drawings
and amended plans those are many
drawings and plans appear from what we
heard to overcome a lot of the concerns
that have been expressed in the report
have those amended plans have they been
considered and your concerns are still
valid
um or are they relatively new amended
plans I'm I'm frightfully confused by it
so the amended plans that were received
um yesterday afternoon which have been
discussed this evening in terms of the
impact on the list of building and the
chimney stock Etc
um due to the the time of receipt
yesterday afternoon we haven't obviously
had the time to accept them and be able
to consider them formally and be able to
reconsort with our conservation officer
and historic England so we haven't been
able to assess
those changes that are contained within
the amended plans
so as it's presented in front of us we
are making a decision on the plans as
they were not the amended plans that
have been put forward
that's correct you're assessing it in
terms of the current submission of the
of the plans not the not the amended
plans that have been referred to
received yesterday lovely that's very
helpful thank you Council Roth
um in which case would it help if we
deferred this in order
we will get to that in the debate I'm
going to get through the questions first
okay so one of the questions I have um
is on the bottom of page 22.
because I just need to see this so
nonetheless the additional height and
proximity at less than two and a half
meters distance of uh
impact significantly on the first floor
south facing windows on unit units three
and four of the townhouse 34 Green Hill
Street have you got a picture of that
have you got can you demonstrate that
because I'm slightly confused about
and it's and and it's two meters you
said
yes let me just share my screen quickly
so it's referring to this distance here
so it's from the side of townhouse eight
which
I'm not sure if you can see my cursor
probably but
um
so yes that it's referring to this
distance here so from the side of
townhouse eight
um to the the side units of those
properties on Green Hill Street and I do
have a photo as well which should help
and just done that relationship
uh yes so the distance is uh less than
two and a half meters
so it's basically shown by this photo so
this is the existing building which
admittedly would be moved slightly
um further away from Green Hill Street
but it would be two meters higher to the
the roof and then you've also got the
the storage element for the reef Gardens
on top of that so it would be almost
four meters higher where it's actually
the central part which is with a storage
bit so it's these windows here that I'm
referring to in the report which are the
kitchen windows for units three and four
so and the distance would be
um less than two and a half meters from
these windows to where the the side
elevation would be in townhouse 8.
so just to follow
the impact of overlooking
so would be from the four meter looking
down yes so the roof Gardens would be
um higher than the existing
um Reef that you can see so they would
be at least two meters higher so that
that would have the ability to look down
onto the windows to some extent but the
main concern is really in terms of that
brick wall and the proximity to those
windows and the impact then on daylight
provision and Outlook from those windows
thank you very much councilor Cargill
please
thank you Charlotte there were two items
there were two two things mentioned
during the presentations one on
ventilation and one lighting could you
just comment on those please
so in terms of the impact on residential
immunity
um
so that the issue raised by
environmental health is regards to noise
so that's disturbance from the nearby
takeaway units on Green Hill Street so
the three units that are in close
proximity to the townhouses and because
of the opening hours that they have
um and in terms of the ability to open
one of the units can open until three
o'clock and obviously that's in tonight
time hours
um and then so we've looked we've
assessed the whole application in terms
of the noise for any prospective
occupiers and environments Health have
raised concerns in that regard
in terms of my assessment I've looked at
whether there are any other mitigating
factors that would be able to be
employed but on in the balance of
assessing a plan application because
there's a number of issues in terms of
immunity I don't consider that that
could be something that could be
employed on this site and in terms of
lighting
because I think that was the look at
cancer cargo if you're going to speak if
you could put your microphone on please
do apologize chair it was the I think it
was the amount of light getting into the
um the buildings that was mentioned
right I see so in terms of the daylight
provision to the Future occupiers the
concerns that I've raised are
predominantly due to the if I just show
you the proposed plan so this is the
first floor plan
um
sorry this is the first floor plan
that's proposed so my concerns are
predominantly to do with the windows
along the northern elevation and the
proximity to this wall here so and at
ground floor level so the windows at
ground floor level are pretty much in
line with this existing straight feature
straight wall there so it's three meters
distance from this point here to the
nearby wall
and then at first for a level because of
the design of the windows it actually
gets closer so it's it's about two
meters proximity for some of the nearest
townhouses so my concern particularly
because those are North facing windows
that they wouldn't have sufficient
daylight or or Outlook because of the
proximity of the existing development
and again in terms of the Southern
elevation as well some of the wind some
of the rooms at ground floor level are
three rooms that they're not going to
have sufficient daylight provision to
the south facing Windows either because
of the two-story Playhouse to the the
southern element of the site so it's
it's both of those factors that have led
me to considered that the impact on
daylight would be quite poor thank you
councilor Harvey please
I share your your um confusion to an
extent there are two strands where in
presentations that we've received where
there's contradictory information one
relates to noise that I picked up
which I think you've already dealt with
to some extent and the other was amenity
space
so in the light I'm confused the the
statements are diametrically opposite so
I'd like to hear what you have to say
about how that might be resolved and
secondly on page 24 25 there is a
reference to the implications of on the
site being occupied as residences on
existing businesses and the
environmental health officer it is
reported has raised objections which you
consider significant so my question is
is the Environmental Health officer on
that basis still concerned and do you
still regard that as significant
yes so in terms of the noise disturbance
levels revised information was received
from the applicant during the life of
the application which was then consulted
but we consulted environmental health
and they have still retained their
objection to the scheme based on the
existing units that are in close
proximity to the site and the levels of
disturbance that they would expect
because of the opening hours and because
of the proximity of the um extraction
equipment
um that's that's in place at the moment
so their concerns are still extant and I
concur with with the objection that
they've raised in terms of the impacts
on immunity for any occupiers of the
townhouses
um in terms of
um the impact on the existing buildings
so you're referring to the the
commercial elements is that correct
it is but
could I could you also respond to the
the amenity question oh yes so in terms
of the private immunity space because
the The Reef Gardens are um what's been
put forward as part of the application
is that the private community space
however because of um the way it's cited
at second floor level and obviously the
ability for
um people to be able to look into that
space it's it's not something that's
considered as private immunity space for
the occupiers
um so that that's why we have considered
that there's no private immunity space
for any of the the townhouses
so in terms of the existing
building that's in relation to the
impact on Commercial properties that's
right so I have
covered this in my reports let me just
refer you to the right section
yeah so it's the close to the bottom of
page 24 so
um in effect we have to look at the
existing situation in terms of current
activities and also other activities
that the businesses could carry out in
terms of their existing licenses as well
so in terms of what's been proposed
the and because of the existing extracts
of the businesses it could be very
likely to create a nuisance for the
occupiers because of the proximity which
could then obviously lead to complaints
for those businesses which could impact
on on the operation of those businesses
Council Parry next please
thank you it's just a little bit of
clarification if I may
um in in the event we progress
um and and there is no deferral
can the officers advise
if if we if that
progressed in that direction and we were
minded to Grant is it possible to
condition the retention of the external
chimney stack as reported in the
presentation from the applicant during
this committee meeting appreciate it in
the amended plans that are yet to be
thoroughly looked at
but on the basis of what the applicant
has said during the committee this
evening
would we need to condition that or is
that not a possibility
my advice would be that as always
members need to consider the plans in
front of you yes amended plans were
submitted but they were submitted so
late in the day that to my mind we can't
have a card to them so my advice would
be that we shouldn't be conditioning
things that are subject to amended plans
when we've confirmed the applicant and
agent that we're not accepting them
cancel Ralph please
um I'm going to bring back the immunity
space issue again because
um I am slightly confused
so
there are roof Gardens
and I think I'm hearing you say
that they're not private
but they're on the roof so why aren't
they private
because of the proximity of nearby
viewpoints you would have views of the
second floor of the development so you
would and certainly in terms of town
houses eight or nine because of the
proximity to the Greenhill street car
park and at the existing residential
units nearby there would be clear views
of of those Gardens
but no
but no one will be looking down on the
gardens
you would only be looking up on the
gardens so those with roof spec roof
Gardens
could make sure that no one from down
below could see
is that right
in terms of their proximity of number 34
Greenhill Street there are windows on
the elevations that would be able to
overlook into the gardens as well
Council post together please
yes so in terms of historic England and
their objections
um are their objections because there
isn't a full or more detailed assessment
of the proposals or are they objecting
on a particular aspect
the objections from historic England are
focused on the fact that the information
is contradictory in part so in terms of
the plans that were submitted and and
the revised information it is quite
contradictory so it hasn't been
clarified in the current submission as
to impacts on the chimney Etc so that
That's the basis of their objection
okay any more points clarification
members
good let's move into debate cancer
Edmond please
thank you share
um I hear a lot of confusion
um
I think there are amended plans in the
offing there's details that could be
clarified and overcome some of the
conditions for refusal
I think that there's an opportunity
where the ward member could also request
a site visit which was also mentioned so
I would like to propose that we defer
please
thank you very much I'll second that and
then I will call in our next speaker who
is councilor Parry
so I was going to second that
Council Dixon
uh no comedian view of the circumstances
Council Rolf
I was going to second that
marvelous okay yeah for me this is It's
become so confusing
um I simply cannot make an appropriate
decision on it if I'm just looking at
what the is in the report and what is
put in front of us which is what we're
supposed to do
um then I I would be inclined to go with
the officer's recommendation
in the knowledge that we have amended
plans and given there is a clear support
from the war member and the Town Council
who represent the town I think it is in
the best interests of us all to make
sure that we do differ and give full
regard to these amended plans and
hopefully we'll come back less confused
and be able to make a proper judgment so
could I have please a show of hands for
those in favor of deferring could I ask
that a site visit is
um involved
um bear with me so
I we had just moved to a vote I'm I am
going to allow you to speak but I want
to need to I need to have very clear
planning reasons why you want to go for
a site visit before we can include that
I think uh during the um uh questions
for clarification
things were not clarified
and I think by seeing the site I think a
lot will come a lot will appear more
distinct and and and I just think it
would help those going on a site visit
to see it personally
cancer had been given it was yourself
that proposed the deferral are you happy
to propose a deferral in order for the
plans to be uh fully assessed and also
to include a site visit for the reasons
we've just heard from Council Rolf
yes chair I'm okay with that okay a
second or I will also agree to that
cancer power you put your hand up would
you like to speak as well
um I was just offering to clarify I
think the site to visit in particular
needs to look at the private amenity the
aspects and the views of that because I
think that is was the key area that was
unclear so
um if if the site visit can be
undertaken the Pacific specifically
draws upon the private immunity space
lovely thank you again councilor Ed and
you're happy with that
in that case uh the proposal is to defer
for the reasons given and also to
conduct a site visit again for the
reasons given could I please have a show
of hands for those in favor of deferral
that is unanimous committee therefore
resolves to defer applications both
applications
2201533 ful
I think I have to take it separately
obviously unfortunately we do have to
take the same one separately for the LBC
so councilor Ed and just to confirm same
reason same uh proposal confirmed you
thank you very much secondly by myself
because I have show of hands for the LBC
councilor Perry Council together we're
we're looking at the LBC the same
proposal has been put thank you very
much that is also unanimous so committee
therefore resolves uh to defer
application 2201534lbc
right I'm going to take a breather while
we have a changeover of our planning
officer
okay now we are fully back to full
service
um uh our presenting officer for
application twenty two zero zero zero
three zero fuel dickensberry Farm is
Alison with us Allison over to you
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
the application
is located to the north of the village
of piloton priors off Walton Lane the
location is shown by the black dot
this
this planning application requests the
change of use of an existing
agricultural building and Associated
hard-standing parking area to the to to
a use to include B8 storage
uh and or a use now called eg3 which
used to be called B1
um for any industrial process which can
be carried out in any residential area
without causing detriment to the
immunity of the area
the building itself requires no
alterations as part of the proposals
alterations to the building including a
small toilet a rock locker room
uh roller shutter doors and cladding on
the south elevation
under concrete four Court have been
approved previously
so here is a recent aerial view of the
site showing the application site
outlined in red down here
it's located off Walton Lane which runs
from piloton priors here just the bottom
of the screen up to the fossway here
Walton Lane is generally three to three
and a half meters in width single
carriageway
and is subject to the National speed
limit 60 miles per hour which changes to
30 miles per hour per hour approximately
90 meters to the south on the approach
to the Village or in this sort of area
here
so
approximately two
approximately 250 meters to the south of
the access
Walton Lane widens slightly to allow two
vehicles to pass
between the site and the widen section
there are a few field Gates and a
further area that is used by vehicles to
pass
that it's acknowledged that there are
few passing places
on the Northern section of Walton Lane
the transport statement concludes the
following trip Generations
so for the B1 use
it's uh worst case scenario would be 25
Vehicles today including three hgvs per
day
and for the B8 storage use it's 13
vehicles per day including zero hdvs
in this particular location there is a
lorry ban already in existence for
Lori's over seven and a half tons
along several of the local Lanes
including Walton Lane
however hgv is over seven and a half
tons who are accessing existing local
businesses along Walden Lane are exempt
from this ban
and there is no restriction as to which
direction through the Lorry ban area the
hgvs can navigate to get to their
businesses
as an alternative to restricting Lorry
movements by condition the applicant has
agreed to enter into a freight
management plan by condition which would
recommend a routing plan
which would be
provided to their suppliers or
um
contractors
and it traffic would be ideally rooted
via kindton Road from the south and not
not to approach from the north from
fossway
so
the
the HG rooting element of the freight
management plan would however be
optional and it would not be able to be
enforced
the
existing agricultural building is here
and this is the concrete four Court
parking it parking and layout plan has
been provided that demonstrates that
there's sufficient space for parking and
turning for the vehicles within the
application site
so
the access onto Walton Lane would be
improved
to provide visibility splays and the
bell the existing bowel mouth would be
widened to allow a car to pass a lorry
um on the access
sections of the existing vegetation
along Walton Lane would have to be
removed but they will be replaced with a
mixed native Hedgerow so this is the
view to the north and this is the view
to the South
you can see the hedgerows
so these are some views of the existing
building
and these are some views of the existing
access
and these are some views of Walton Lane
itself
to illustrate the situation a bit more
I've also got a video
so if you bear with I'll
so this is uh starting off in piloton
priors itself just at the very uh start
of Walton Lane
so you can see through the trees which
have no leaves on at the moment you can
see the existing Barn
just here where my cursor is I don't
know if you can see that
so if I just uh
so that the video takes you up the road
past dickensary farm so you can see the
existing Lanes
oh
oh let me go
all right there you go
so the road is a bit wider towards the
Southern Southern section
so this is now heading north out of
piloton prize towards towards the
fossway
this was the speed limit
so this is dickensberry Farm approaching
on the left
Pedro that would be removed
I won't carry on right to the very end
because it's quite long I just wanted
you to have a feel for the character of
the area
enough yeah
okay
so uh that's the end of my presentation
so Mr chairman there are no updates
um and the recommendation is the
application be granted for the reasons
detailed in the report subject to the
conditions and notes wording and
numbering delegated to offices
thank you awesome thank you very much
indeed let's call our first speaker on
this item who is Dave mcwhirter I think
I've pronounced that correctly I hope I
have
marvelous
Mr mcwhurter is the vice chairman of
person prior's Parish Council and once
you're sat comfortable and ready to go
if you press the button on the right of
your speaker and the floor will be yours
I will of course you have three minutes
I'll give you 30 second warning I should
have said that before when you're ready
the floor is yours
the parish council objects to this
application we believe the proposal
would breach policy as-10 of the course
strategy which relates to the
countryside in villages and States all
proposals May thoroughly assessed to
avoid a level of increase in traffic on
Rural roads that would be harmful to the
local area
the issue here is the road access it's
interesting you've just seen it it's a
road access it makes it an unsuitable
site for a storage and distribution
Depot
Walton Lane is a narrower single
carriageway it's used by villagers for
recreational walking dog walking jogging
that sort of stuff horse riding there
are virtually no opportunities for
vehicles to pass one another it has a
seven and a half ton weight limit but
Vehicles above that limit can use it if
they're loading or unloading so you
actually have the potential here for
heavy Goods Vehicles well above seven
and a half tons to be accessing this
site
on the road she saw we argue that
granting permission will result in an
unacceptable increase in Goods field
because coming along through the village
and using Walton Lane
interestingly our concerns have been
shared by the county highways originally
objected in the letter of the 10th of
February last year County highway state
the highway Authority has concerns with
regard to intensification of use of
Walton Lane
in a further letter at the end of May
after the transport statement I was
again clearly uncomfortable made the
point that without details of the user
of the B1 or the B8 distribution
facility they were quote unable to
wholly agree unquote with some of the
figures
the transport statement estimates an
additional 38 vehicles per day
we argue this is just finger in the air
because we don't know who is going to
use the facility and until you know
who's going to use it what sort of
business it's going to be used for how
on Earth can you say how many vehicles
are going to be using it so that is
simply just not believable from us
you might consider attaching conditions
to the permission
we would argue the planning office
report contains 20 20 conditions 20 and
if you're up at 20 you've got some
issues about this place
and I'd also politely remind you that
this site has a history of
non-compliance with conditions such as
Stratford District Council to the
applicant to court over animal carcass
issues some years ago 30 seconds and in
any event the fundamental issue is the
road is not suitable for heavy Goods
vehicles and nothing you can do to
change that
we urge you to refuse the application on
the grounds that Walton Lane is
unsuitable for heavy Goods vehicles
that the potential for an increase in
Goods Vehicles is open-ended because we
don't know who is going to use it and
all of this contravenes policy as-10
which is designed to protect the
villages and Rural roads thank you
spot on your time thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
Parish Council
councilor Cargill please thank you very
much
um you mentioned about highways but I
noticed that highways now have no
objection so have they always been
addressed uh always concerned
well I we're very disappointed that
highways have have withdrawn from the
discussion they originally objected they
called for a transport statement which
was assigned to judge how many vehicles
were likely to be using it for a B1
facility and how many for a B8 facility
so the transport statement came up with
these figures of 25 additional vehicles
for a B1 and and 13 for a B8 but
interestingly even in the transport
statement they said but these figures
are a little bit uh uncertain because it
depends who's going to be using it
highways then locked onto the 25
vehicles for the B1 and ignored the B8
thing altogether and so seemed to have
withdrawn their objection
on half of the information that was
available to us and no matter how many
times we go back to highways and said
what's going on why have you done this
it's fair to say we don't get any
response to that so I cannot give you a
satisfactory reason but clearly from the
letters don't particularly like it
thank you very much Council Harvey
please
um I understand your concern about the
veracity of the numbers that have been
put forward as potential uh traffic
movements does the parish council have
any information on existing level of
traffic because I'm trying to get a
sense of what the additional burden
might be on top of what do you have any
information
uh gosh I wouldn't like to be nailed to
the wall on on the Precision of the
figures but I think it talked about I
mean it's essentially Walton Lane is a
rat run there are the two Farms there's
dickensberry Farm as you come up from
the village they can perform to a riot
and another Farm to your left and after
that you've got a mile that takes you to
the force way so it's it's private cars
sometimes you can get two or three an
hour uh rush hours you'll get them then
and then for hours you won't see anybody
on it at all you'll see a few farm
tractors we get quite a few of those but
I can't give you a figure I'm afraid
other than to say
two things really one is even if it's 38
additional vehicles
that is a significant increase we feel
and in any event you can't trust the 38
where does that figure come from
thank you very much anyone else have any
questions for our Parish Council
no in that case councilman weather thank
you very much your time contribution of
course your patience this evening as
well
now members um I made a bit of a mistake
earlier uh I you will remember during
the disclosures I mentioned that we had
received an email from our Ward member
for this item it came in at a very late
hour as we were prepping and organizing
ourselves for tonight and the inference
was that the war member was registered
to speak and on that basis I said that I
would read out the statement that had
been made it has now transpired that the
war member is not registered to speak so
even if the war member was here they
would not be afforded the time to be
heard so I am not going to read out the
statement that has been provided
hopefully you will have you it came
through not long after five so you may
have had a chance to read it what I will
say is the main points contained within
it are the same that we have just heard
from the parish council and it is of an
objection
um so I just wanted to make that very
clear so we can move to points of
clarification from our officers
councilor Parry please
thank you I wonder whether the officers
can give me some indication of the
weight that can be attributed to as10
and in particular the the point on uh
the impact on Rural roads
um so as as10 is an up-to-date policy
within our core strategy members can
give that full weight so if members
consider that it doesn't comply with
that part of as10 and there's therefore
a breach that could potentially form a
reason for refusal quite reasonably in
terms of considering the development
plan we obviously don't have injection
from County highways but it is within
as10 so
cancel Roth please
uh thank you Alison could you just
reiterate what you said about the
tonnage and the uh whether it's
enforceable or not could you just I
think I know but if you could just
explain again thank you
so in the area
there is a a ban on lorries over seven
and a half tons
so which includes Walton Lane
so existing businesses though are exempt
including Walton Lane
so
there's no restriction as to which
direction through the Lorry Barn area
HD hgvs visiting existing businesses
can go they can approach from either
direction
so basically what you're saying there is
no restriction at all
if the vehicle has a legitimate reason
for being there
um so it they can't use what known as a
Rat Run
but if it's to visit an existing built
an existing business for unloading or
loading
they can visit it
so
uh so and that's for me the direction
but the applicant has has agreed to
enter into a voluntary agreement
but obviously we wouldn't be able to
monitor that very easily because we have
no con no method of monitoring who's
going where or doing what
Council Cargill please
thank you Allison a couple of points if
I may one is just following up on that
particular Point
um you mentioned that the width of the
road is around about 3.5 meters
um I know that
hdvs are in the region about 2.9 meters
and we're happy about the fact that
there shouldn't be any more damage to
the verges answers because of um you
know large vehicles and people do walk
down there we saw that so are they
concerned about that first
um
the
the Walton Lane is a single carriageway
there's not enough space for vehicles to
pass each other
and there are very few passing places I
can't deny that
however
there are at the moment Farm Vehicles
which travel up and down and there is
existing traffic there's no incidences
of any accidents on the road
um and
but you can see from the video that
there is evidently damaged to the
highway verges already
from the current level of traffic
thank you chair okay that's fine thank
you the other point I just wanted to
pick up on was the uh the Hedge removal
of the Hedge of creative visibility
splay I assume I didn't apply pick that
up correctly um I'll be happy from a
council point of view that that is
permissible and it's not going to damage
ancient Hedgerow or anything like that
uh no definitely no it's predominantly
Le Landy I Hedge
so uh so any and the visibility splays
would be either in highways land or the
applicant's ownership so it can
be replanted by condition thank you so
that would represent an improvement I
think thank you
councilor Harvey please yeah Allison
could you confirm that there are no
other businesses other than the two
farms at the southern end of Walton Lane
in Walton Lane
question one question two
do we have any do you have any
information about the movement of
Vehicles over seven and a half tons to
the existing two businesses I do they
come how many are there and do they tend
to come from the south from from piloton
or from the north from the Foss
um there was a transport statement
submitted but it doesn't doesn't go into
the detail of what direction the traffic
has come from
um there is on-site already that there
are two uses there's kind of existing
farming activities
um which are include feed deliveries and
movements of cattle which is about two
to three hgvs per week uh in addition to
that there's an existing DIY livery
business on site on the same site which
is daily daily upkeep is about six cars
and then larger horse boxes about two to
four at the weekends both of those
activities are going to carry on they're
not proposing to cease those
so the from the from the from the change
of use and if it was to be a
um like a B1 use the worst case scenario
is 25 vehicle movements per day on top
of what's already coming in and out of
the site
okay members do we have any more points
for clarification to our officers
no in that case let's move into debate
who would like to kick us off councilor
off
um
Allison mentioned earlier that there
were no instances of accidents
on the road but I that's not to say that
the increase of traffic won't cause
more uh accidents I I personally have
concerns about the increased traffic and
the uh we saw on the video Walkers and
how close cars would be to those walkers
and to have some of the european-sized
lorries
going down that single Track Road
um uh sends alarm bells to me
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman um
I think we all know our rural parts of
this this County and we've all got some
narrow Lanes in those parts we can't
control the traffic which goes along
them we can't uh prevent uh lorries I
don't think over seven and a half tons
who aren't delivering actually going
along there it was described as a wrap
run
um it's a Pity it is a rat run to the
fast presumably
um but essentially I cannot see a valid
playing reason for refusing this
application and therefore I will propose
that we Grant it in accordance with the
officer's recommendation
thank you very much cancer Cargill
please
thank you this is always a tricky one
with these sort of things on the one
hand yes there is obviously an increase
in traffic I'm sure there will be and it
is a very narrow road
on the other we are here to try and
encourage rural businesses and and
encourage them to thrive and so it's a
real real sort of problem on balance
however I I go with a counter-dixon I
feel that this is
um a reasonable application and I with
the traffic management plan
I feel that it is quite achievable
I'm willing to propose
a second second I apologize second
marvelous thank you very much indeed
councilor together next please
yeah I just wanted to Echo councilor
rolls concerns
um I mean the road is a single Truck
Country Lane and of course there is
already
um agricultural related traffic
um of course this this is a change of
views so they'll be different I suppose
type of agvs and traffic and I'm
concerned about the intensification
especially if it's used by cyclists by
Earth Riders by workers
um I yes I'm I'm very concerned as well
and and the freight management plan
if I understood correctly cannot be
enforced and is optional I'm not even
sure you can implement it whether you
know who's going to tell them how you
divert or would traffic re-routed but
obviously if you can't enforce it it's
it's really not
um you know I don't think it's something
that we can
think about or consider and so yes my
concerns are mainly about the the
intensification of traffic and I see the
policy aes10 and you know applications
are obviously supported however they
need to avoid the level of increasing
traffic on Rural roads
that would be harmful to the area so to
the local area so I'm minded of that
thank you but I I also appreciate the
balance of
um supporting rural businesses so it's
very challenging application thank you
thank you cancer Parry please
thank you jet I think the Crux of this
whole application is the fact that we
don't have an objection from highways I
think if we
um were having a an objection from
highways this would give us
um
straightforward reason to refuse this
application
here we are again when highways I'm
afraid do a little bit of their Desktop
review of applications
as the cabinet portfolio holder for
economic development I'm obviously very
mindful that we need to be growing
business across the district
and I'm also mindful of the fact that
were we to refuse
this would go to appeal because we
actually haven't got any solid material
planning reason for refusal we should be
doing everything we can to promote rural
businesses I have every sympathy with
the parish council I know that
particular Road
and have used it frequently I would also
be equally concerned if the freight
management plan
insisted that the hdvs use the Kyneton
road so that actually went through pilot
and Hersey Butler's Marston Etc
it is a difficult one we're always here
to make the difficult decisions
I don't like this application
but I am minded to support the officer's
recommendation because I do not see with
the highways having no objection we have
no other uh rationale but to Grant
application thank you chair thank you
very much anyone else councilor Andrew
Serafin thank you do we know if highways
actually paid a site visit
um I have had lengthy lots of lengthy
conversations with them
but I don't know
in my discussions it was clear that they
knew the site and knew the road and the
road conditions but I don't know either
way whether they actually physically
went there in connection with this
application
okay before I throw my two planes
working as anyone else want to have a go
no I'm I think Council Paris hit the
nail on the head entirely this this
application hinges on the highways we
have a no objection from the highways
the reality is that road is a 60 mile an
hour road and anyone within the limit
set to the road can go up and down it at
60 miles an hour I mean it's having seen
the video that is quite frightening to
think that someone would but the reality
is that is the limit set to the road
um so I they're on as far as I can see
no planning reasons to go against this
so I will also be sporting officers
recommendation now we have a proposal to
Grant from cancer Dixon it has been
seconded by cancer Cargill so could I
please have a show of hands for those in
favor of granting this application
six and those against please
three uh so committee therefore resolves
to Grant application
2200030 ful at dickensbury Farm in
pilton priors
let's move on to our final application I
think Council Dixon is going to make his
way to the viewing gallery
while he does that we will have a change
of planning officer so Victoria Kempton
will be joining us imminently
and what she has and she sat and
comfortable uh we will be hearing
application reference
2202099 ful A month's Hall Sports field
in Tamworth in Arden
Victoria whenever you're ready and
comfortable it's over to you
thank you chair
permission is sought to construct an
artificial Cricket strip at Muntz Hall
Sports field the application site is
located at the western edge of tanworth
in Arden and is marked by the black dot
on the map
this slide shows that this slide shows
the site outlined in red with the
village of town within Arden to the east
in terms of constraints the site lies
within the open Countryside Greenbelt
and Ireland special landscape area
the site is also near to the
conservation area as outlined in pink
whilst the dash line the dash Green Line
shows a position of a public
right-of-way which runs parallel with
the southern boundary
this plan shows the position and angle
of the proposed artificial strip which
would measure around 30 meters by 2.7
meters with an area of 83 square meters
the black circle indicates the overall
area of the pitch although this does not
form part of the application
this aerial image shows the site in
relation to the village with the
Residential Properties to the East and
Southeast with open Countryside beyond
the other boundaries
the existing ground has been used as a
football pitch with informal games in
the summer
in addition to this there are also
tennis courts to the south of the site
along with a pavilion and and building
for scouting organized organizations to
the east of the pitch
photo number one is a view looking to
the West with a football goal just in
view
whilst the second photos of you looking
towards the east with a pavilion and
Scout building
these are a couple more photos with
image number one showing the tennis
courts photo number two pans slightly
round to the right in the direction of
the public footpath
so this concludes my presentation the
application is recommended for approval
subject to the conditions listed in the
report however should members be minded
to approve the application an additional
condition should be added to control the
plans
thank you chair
okay sorry thank you very much indeed
let's call our one and only speaker on
this item who is the one only counselor
Tony Dixon
good evening Council Dixon you've got
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up the floor
is yours good evening chairman and thank
you members I won't take up three
minutes first of all I'd just like to
thank Victoria for her patience with
this application which landed on her
desk I think back in August
um I was surprised actually that the
provision of a artificial strip which
probably can't be seen by anybody except
somebody stood on it when you're
actually there actually did require
planning consent and permissions and I
do wonder whether or not other Cricket
grounds Etc might already have them
without planning permission but that's a
that's an aside
what I would mention is that the nearest
neighbors are supportive of the
application
um they in fact one of them actually
recalls when Cricket used to be played
on the field until the 1970s so
essentially it's a request by the months
trust the month's trust started over a
hundred years ago when this field was
donated to the community
I'm the chairman of the local trust and
the local Cricket Club would like to
come back unfortunately there isn't
space to play football and Cricket on
the same Sports field and needed to say
when the field is used or has been in
use by the soccer team essentially the
playing surface is just not appropriate
for Cricket and essentially you've
either got to choose one or the other
and would rather have a local cricket
team rather than
a football team soccer team from across
the borders in Worcestershire who were
the previous users of our Sports Fitch
I'm very happy to take any questions
from Members thank you
members do we have any questions for
Council Dixon Council Cargill please
thank you Council Dixon I notice in the
conditions
um on item two it says match materials
to match those listed uh color to be
green are you happy with that
yes I am Mr chairman yes
yes uh I've Council a question for you
um what's your batting average last
season
let's move on okay there'd be no further
questions thank you very much indeed uh
members do we have any questions for our
officers councilor Harvey am I right in
thinking that the only reason that we're
considering this application is
predominantly because it's an artificial
pitch
is it the question is is it the case
that if this Sports Club had decided to
install a natural pitch without an
artificial element there would be no
need for consent
so we didn't issue a lawful development
certificate on the application but we
did feel that the construction of the
artificial pitch would be development
which doesn't fall under any permitted
development rights so we felt as it was
development it would require planning
permission
so I think it's fair to say that
generally speaking if it was proper
grass there's no change of you so it
would probably wouldn't need planning
permission I can't say for sure without
ldp but
so Harvey's going to make a grass
Cricket Wicket in his garden now I think
um okay uh in that case let's move into
debate um who would like to kick us off
councilor Parry please
I'd like to propose that we Grant in
accordance with the officer's
recommendation
and councilor Eden please
in the absence of councilor Crump I'm
far from stumped on this one very much
I'm very much for it
there we go right our second councilor
Perry's proposal marvelous thank you
very much anyone else want to have their
say no let's move to the vote so we're
Pros those to Grant inline we've also
recommendation could have a show of
hands please in favor please that is
unanimous marvelous um members I don't
believe we have any urgent business no
in that case I will call the meeting to
a close thank you very much indeed and
we'll see you next week